Say Alice and Bob are on opposite sides of
the universe.
Entanglement means that somehow, Alice measuring
her particle affects Bob’s one even though
it’s a world away immediately.
If that’s the case, then the question of
this video is “why can’t they use quantum
mechanics to communicate instantly”?
This video is very much a sequel to a video
I made about entanglement and the EPR paradox
so it will help a lot to watch that first.
Actually, these videos are part of a series
on quantum mechanics so start here if you’re
new.
Back to the question.
Let’s say Bob wants the answer to a yes
or no question that he’s asked Alice, but
she’s waited till she’s very far away
to think of an answer.
However luckily, they have an entangled pair
of particles between them.
Here’s a possibility.
Alice tells Bob in advance that if he measures
his particle to be up, the answer is yes,
down is no.
Now all Alice has to do is nonlocally influence
his particle to be up, say and then they’ve
communicated faster than light!
But obviously that won’t work, no matter
what she does, her own outcome is random,
and since Bob just gets the opposite, his
outcome just comes out completely random as
well.
So that scheme doesn’t work- but a lot of
you suggested a much more devious plan.
I’ve been saying for ages that you can tell
the difference between a state in a superposition
of two possibilities, and one that’s merely
one of the other of these but you don’t
know which.
Why not use that?
If Alice measures, the whole state collapses
and is not in a superposition anymore.
Then surely Bob can do some interference experiment
and if he sees no interference, he knows that
Alice has done her measurement, otherwise
she hasn’t.
Alice can communicate what she wants by choosing
whether to measure her particle or not.
Then they could use this scheme, and communicate
instantly across the universe!!
Ok, that sounds great but obviously Quantum
mechanics has a way around that too.
I’ll explain it, but this is the punch line.
With this entangled state, you can tell they’re
in a superposition by doing some measurement
that shows interference.
However, that measurement is a measurement
where you have to interact both of the particles
in some way to do the measurement, and so
you need both particles in the same place.
If you instead only do the measurement on
one of the particles, or both particles, but
not together, there’s no way for you to
tell the difference between the state where
they’re in superposition or when they’re
not.
To see this, let’s look at what happens
when Bob does his measurement in the case
where Alice did hers already, or choose not
to.
These are the states in either case.
In the case where Alice has measured, his
particle really is up or down now, but he
doesn’t know which.
But then say Bob does a measurement of the
left and rightness of a particle.
We know that if we did this to a particle
that’s up, it will go either left or right
randomly.
Same thing for a down particle.
So even though we don’t know which it is,
up or down, we know it will randomly go left
or right, and this is the no interference
result that we talked about in some previous
videos.
This is kind of what we expected.
But what happens in the second case where
the state is still in a superposition?
This is a bit tricky.
What you need to do is write the state, in
particular Bob’s particles state, in the
left/right basis.
Try it and then see if you can figure out
what happens.
OK, so here’s the maths.
All I’ve done is subbed in these expressions.
Then, I’m grouping up the left and right
options for Bob’s particle.
Then you can see that both options have the
same weight, so they’re both equally likely.
What this means is, if Bob measures his particle
for left rightness when Alice hasn’t measured,
the particle is equally likely to go left
or right- which is the same as if she had
measured, so you can’t tell the difference.
But you might protest that I’ve only showed
you that this plan for faster than light communication
is foiled for this particular entangled state,
but what about other ones.
There are way way way more possible entangled
states that just this.
I just use this for an example most of the
time because this state has the maximum possible
amount of entanglement, but in fact most 2
particle states are entangled.
For example, this state is entangled.
So what would we need to show that using any
entangled state is useless for faster than
light communication?
You need to prove that no matter what Alice
does on her side, that doesn’t affect Bob’s
measurement outcomes.
For example, in either case when Alice does
or doesn’t choose to do a measurement, Bob
get’s up or down with the same probability
either way.
This can be proved generally, but it’s a
bit tough.
Instead I’m going to get you to do it for
an example that’s quite a bit more challenging
that the one I did.
Prove it for this state, when Alice measures
up and down-ness, but Bob measures left-rightness.
I’m going to write a detailed solution in
the description, but ask me if you get confused.
So yes, entanglement is useless for faster
than light communication, but can we try use
it for something else?
Say Alice and Bob have lots of entangled particles
between them.
If they measure them all, then the outcomes
are random, but they know what the other persons
outcome is.
So they share a string of random bits.
Your second homework is to look up and explain
the usefulness of something called a ‘one-time
pad’.
Also, comment on whether or not an encryption
based on a one time pad coming from this set
up is secure or not if they know Eve might
be trying to intercept the particles.
This is the topic for the next video.